Fox News propaganda's Tucker Carlson has
been exposed as actually hating Trump
quote passionately these text messages
were released as part of the Dominion
voting system's defamation lawsuit
against Fox News for 1.6 billion dollars
and the big story here is of course the
hypocrisy these Fox News hosts don't
believe half of the things they say in
the aftermath of the November 2020
election you had Tucker and Sean Hannity
and Laura Ingram and others claiming
that Trump's claims about a stone
election were reasonable claims they
were realistic they were fact-based when
in fact they knew that they were not
they were texting behind the scenes that
Sydney Powell that crazy lawyer was
crazy and we now learned that despite
putting a very positive public-facing
perspective on Trump Tucker Carlson
hated Trump quote passionately so what
happens now do the Trump supporting
Tucker viewers tune out probably not